your 60th birthday you are obsessed with
talking about my age what do you mean he
is obsessed with talking about Milestone
you'll bring it up what's this got to do
with me you because you have brought it
up on the podcast easily seven times
easily seven times you said well I'm
gonna turn 50 but that means Conan's
turning 60. I want to keep this on the
down low comedy's all about being young
and I'm putting it out there that I'm in
my late 40s and you every single time we
get on Micah like well in three more
months someone's going to be 60 and then
it's just a hop skipping a jump to 70.
how are you big boy wow this is you left
right and Center lately what is
happening
I don't want to die touchy why it's the
grave the grave beckons but it's just a
number man oh yeah it's a number that
you keep bringing up again and again and
again six zero